how big is
her you've seen her right we all did hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but my
friend Bill Mah probably maybe said
something that kind of made sense but
also didn't make sense and I'm working
on you Bill come on man you'll get there
the um people who don't know who Leah
Thomas is I do because I've read about
her she is the
trans swimmer who beat you we
tied I did not get beat um I get called
beat you in the locker room with a big
there we go in that
case how big is her you've seen her
right we all did how big is it I
mean what what kind of a is it
describer let's see um well I don't
want to see it just wanted to hear it
just well if I had to see it you have to
hear it first of all this is a 6'4 man
right well trans woman a man male okay
this is what she would claim um and she
does go through life as a woman correct
like a woman with male parts yeah yeah
right I know I'm just trying to like the
like paint the port okay wait can I I'll
be frank
here I don't use she her pronouns when
referring to Thomas and I call it a male
I think even using the term trans woman
is giving Thomas some of our language as
women and I think transwoman is a subset
of male I do not believe trans women are
women